hey what is up guys I'm Kay PhD here and
I promise this video because some of you
asked for it this is the what's in my
bag at CES 2014 video because I'm here
in the hotel room and here's my bag now
my values and all that interesting but I
figured I'd show you guys this because
the actual setup the whole idea of going
CES with camera gear is to keep it as
lightweight as possible but to still
have as much as you would like to do in
terms of production as possible so I'm
going to take you basically through what
I'm bringing to CES now the first thing
that would be in my bag that's not is
the camera that I'm recording this with
and that's the Canon c100 and the lens
on it which is a 17 to 55 millimeter F
2.8 with is so I'll go right in the body
of the bag and that is everything I'm
doing in terms of main visuals and then
in the corner of this bag up here I have
a sort of an establishing lens shot this
is the Tokina 11 to 16 F 2.8 so this is
a really wide angle lens and it's about
as wide as you can go on the c100 to get
those really wide shots you've probably
seen before audio stuff and this is a
pretty intense bag as you can see here
and I'll get to a showing of the entire
bag in a second but we have I have a
Sennheiser MKH 416 microphone and that
goes in a side pocket so I'll show you
guys that in a second and then there's
this a little outdoor foam thing I look
dirty but that's the way that you cover
up the mic outside and not get any wind
noise so I'll take that out I also have
some massive batteries for the Canon
c100 honestly it lasts a really long
time on the battery I have in it maybe
five hours of recording time but this is
the standard sized battery that will get
me an additional three so you got to
have that lastly for monitoring audio
you probably all saw this coming
these are the audio technica ath M 50s
these are the run black ones they have
the removable cable on the back and they
are what I use for monitoring audio
plugs directly into the c100 over on the
side here is a lavalier microphone
because I'm carrying the zoom h4n and
this is an XLR version of the second cos
11 D it's a great basically broadcast
quality
microphone that'll go on your shirt or
whatever as a lavalier I don't
necessarily use lavell ears all that
much but if I were to conduct an
interview or I need to get off camera
audio like I am right now
lavel ear is very useful this is the
front or the top of the bag and while
we're talking about the bag this is the
canva roadie to backpack it's the only
bag I could really find on the entire
internet that could fit a fully
assembled c100 which basically means it
has the microphone and the lens on it
and I had it in this bag while I was
traveling so that's this is the bag I
have a couple of front compartments so
first compartment it's basically just SD
cards batteries you can probably see
this and and of course a business card
and I have an external battery I found a
lot of people take some massive external
batteries I'm not taking a huge one but
this is one for Motorola that I like
because it has built-in USB cable in
this middle compartment here this is
basically made for just laptops and that
is what I have what I've been using for
school and what I keep coming back to is
the 13-inch retina MacBook Pro has don't
judge me this is a decal girl sticker
that's the only place I could find where
we get it but it's a matte black sticker
on it that keeps it looking pretty clean
and this is a pretty compact and what
I've been using for on-the-go video
editing fits right in the front of the
backpack this backpack also has a top
compartment made specifically for audio
but I have some smaller things in here
basically so when you take a look at
this you're going to have the smaller
accessories number one my favorite my
beloved this is the Sony rx100 Mark two
point shoot basically the best portable
video I could have in my pocket and I
recorded all of CES last year with the
mark 1
so basically excellent camera proven
camera I also have my j-bird blue buds
ex I listen to these while I was
traveling to CES so I had these in the
front of my backpack all the time
wireless audio this is my Galaxy Note 3
along with the two other phones that
I've showed you guys on Twitter that I'm
carrying the Stormtrooper black and
white Nexus 5 and the iPhone 5s so these
are the three devices that
well we'll pretty much keep me juiced
for the entire show if I need to share
stuff with you like I promised I'd be
sharing things on Twitter so that's
where the note 3 is it's sort of a
secondary and this is the foam cover for
the zoom h4n
because we notice I'm going to use it
outside this is the shotgun holder so
when I have the mk8 416 on top of the
microphone or on top of the camera this
is where the mic will sit and I also
have my business cards so if you find me
you can have one then there's all this
miscellaneous stuff a battery for the
rx100 a microfiber a hot shoe adapter
all kinds of other stuff like that but
that's basically it so this is one side
of the bag and boom all I have in here
is a zoom h4n this is my audio beast
this is where the foam head will go this
is where the sank and cos 11d microphone
will plug in this is the preamp this is
everything this goes right inside and on
the other side is of course a 2 terabyte
external hard drive because the retina
MacBook Pro that I showed you only has
128 gigs of internal storage so this is
a USB 3.0 external hard drive from
Western Digital and that will be my
scratch disk for editing which I use
Adobe Premiere by the way you probably
knew that if you've seen the gear list
in the description and lastly in this
specifically made audio compartment is
the shotgun microphone so this is the
XLR audio technica or CIN Sennheiser MKH
416 microphone that I use for basically
every video I've made in the past like 4
months it's an awesome mic so that is
what is in those side compartments
all right so this is what everything
looks like laid out through glass you
can see everything I talked about that
I'll have on the show floor it's
actually not all that much if you think
about it and of course what I didn't
mention here is my Nexus 10 came with me
on the plane my iPad Mini but those
won't be with me on a show for so this
is what I have to fit in the 10 ba roti
to bag and there it is there's the c100
fully assembled the headphones a lens
that's everything in the back and a
backpack is done